[Music]
by now we are aware of the difference
between elements compounds and mixtures
do you remember the differences mixtures
are like food items that we consume
they contain everything in proportion
that we desire we can add or remove a
substance according to our need
compounds on the other hand are those
which have substances in fixed
proportion so if you change the
proportion of substances it will affect
the compound and render it changed for
instance if you remove even one hydrogen
from h2o that is water the composition
changes and water as a compound does not
exist thus fixed proportion is a must in
compounds lastly we have the elements
these are the purest forms of any known
substance they are composed of only the
same type of atoms there are neither
proportions nor random mixing of
substances so can we say that compounds
and mixtures are made up of elements
absolutely so in nature it implies that
elements are the basic forms of every
material that we find around and hence
in order to study every substance around
us we need to begin with studying the
various elements so where do we begin
maybe the reactivity or maybe the
physical properties first right I'm
asking if we can study the reactivity
and physical properties of each of the
elements is that feasible well all these
would have been valid only if the
elements would be few in numbers do you
know the number of elements that exist
astonishingly the number of elements
that we find naturally occurring is 98
while the total number of elements known
to mankind is 118 so how do we study
each element individually for all its
properties looking at the number of
elements that exist I don't think it
would be convenient to pick every
element individually
study all the properties right imagine
you have to organize the kitchen you
will not place any vessel or eatable
randomly anywhere you will organize the
shelves and refrigerator in the most
convenient way which is suitable for
your needs
similarly for studying so many elements
we need to organize them appropriately
an organization begins with arrangement
yes
arranging the various elements is the
first step towards understanding their
properties and arrangement is possible
only if we categorize them right this is
how we organize the elements and this
process of categorization helps the
study the elements with ease in other
words we've classified the elements here
classification of elements is
categorizing the various elements into
groups based on similarities and
differences in their properties the
classification system helps us in
grouping the various elements into
categories which we refer to as the
periods hence the system is also
referred to as the periodic
classification of elements let's get to
know how periodic classification was
carried out in the early days of
emerging chemistry when not many
elements were known to people in the
upcoming videos we will understand the
various classification systems put forth
by the different legendary personalities
[Music]